uk has today taken the decision to ban
rivals on flights from south america
portugal
and cape verde it's because of fears
around a new variant of covet 19 known
as
the brazil variant it was first detected
on sunday when japan's health ministry
said it had discovered the variant in
four travelers
who arrived in tokyo from brazil's
amazonas
states researchers in brazil say the new
variant
named p1 was identified in 42
of positive samples collected and
sequenced
in the city of manaus boris johnson
says that he is concerned about the
variant
but why well the brazil variant is said
to feature
12 mutations in the spike protein with
many of these
similar to those found in the already
known variants
first found in the uk and in south
africa
the n501y mutation
is present in all three variants and
it's associated with causing higher
transmissibility but tests by pfizer
biontech
found their vaccine can still target
this key mutation two further mutations
e484k and k417t
can be found in both the brazilian and
south african
variants these have been shown to help
covert 19
bypass the immune system but it's not
yet known
what impact they could have on vaccines
so far we don't know if the brazil
variant is in the uk but tests are
ongoing in labs like these
in oxford and portland down to learn
more alongside the uk's decision to ban
inbound flights scientists at the heart
of the research
who were pivotal to sequencing this new
variant
say more genomic surveillance is needed
to contain the spread viruses known as
borders and can spread very rapidly
around the world so if we want to
rapidly detect and potentially contain
the new p1 lineage or any other lineage
that might emerge
elsewhere i think we should start
looking at increasing genomic
surveillance across locations
in countries that are directly linked by
for example air travel
to local to places where local
transmission of these new lineages have
occurred
for now the banning of inbound flights
is the only
option to slow the spread of the brazil
variant but
as the virus continues to mutate
and change scientists will be watching
very closely to make sure
all available vaccines are still
effective